if texas doesn't work out for you
there's a city called new york city and
the mayor de blasio pushing forward with
legalized heroin
sites for new york city this is not a
babylon b story this is not an onion
this is a real story de blasio pushing
forward would legalize heroin injection
sites for new york city this is a
post-millennial story when is de
blasio's last day in office he's got a
couple months left hey tyler can you
pull up the story so people can see it
as cities across the u.s reject
legalized heroin injection sites and
needle exchanges mayor de blasio is
planning to resurrect a long-delayed
plan to open supervised heroin injection
sites in new york city even as the big
apple uh
grapples with a massive surge in
overdose that's an open air drug use on
city streets in the middle of the day de
blasio has called the shooting galleries
an idea whose time has come and said he
was moving forward with the
controversial proposal because he had
the kind of potential cooperation he
needed from president biden governor
kathy hokul which by the way
biden and kathy probably don't want that
endorsement if they're getting it and
it's real it's not a good look for them
either earlier this month hoco signed a
law discriminate the crim
decriminalizing the possession or sale
of
hypodermic needles and syringes the new
law
led to new york uh nypd is showing a
directive allowing the uh addicts to
shoot up in public what did this this
what the hell is this it's so
incomprehensible what the hell is this
all about like
who have you lost your mind like so
here's what i'm wondering what does this
do
so so does a mother say what you know
what babe great let's move to new york
city
let's take the kids over there
especially if you're not to begin with
concerned about homelessness
safety
violence
crime and then this is the i would like
to have a business that was in a block
or two of that area where you can shoot
up but i'm i'm honestly i don't think
these people are so dumb they're not
idiots what is your outcome of doing
that can we play devil's advocate
everybody give me one reason why you
would do this okay devil's advocate if i
fight
to keep an area where if you're going to
be a heroin addict we're going to offer
you a safe place to do it and you can
come here and it's not illegal and
you're going to do it anyway so we're
going to get you away from the suburbs
or away from downtown or away from times
square then you come over here in the
meatpacking district and shoot up seven
i don't understand this okay no no we're
we're about to we're about to learn
about mr de blasio that i published i
published this
one more time one more time
okay what you're looking right at right
there changing death rate from 20 2019
we have an epidemic we have an epidemic
of youth death in this country and he
wants to do something like that what is
it for is that drug overdose or what is
that it's drug overdoses it's suicide
it's it's
something laced with fentanyl
wait wait go back to this i'm trying to
understand what this is go back to this
i didn't see the data go back tyler just
swipe there you go that's okay so it's
the it's the one on the bottom it's
bottom of page seven
kicked me out
to the rescue wow this is exactly the
moment for kai emergency is loving it
because great glass he's uh
he's seen as a hero right now this is
what you call the hegelian dialectic
you set somebody up for failure
they fail you coming as the hero
let me show you how it's done
he's reading too much of 40 laws of
power
kai do you want me to redrop it yeah
just re-drop it okay wait how did you do
that though
okay while they're doing that while
they're doing that let me go back to the
story you were saying so the only reason
david you're somebody that's how do you
process this yourself
yeah i agree with tom it's somewhere if
we want to play devil's advocate you
could say yeah it's somewhere where you
can do it away from all the suburbs and
just kind of do it in your own safe
little corner there's a safe haven to do
how's that working out in los angeles or
it's someone if you want to wean off of
heroin and you can want to micro dose it
and kind of slowly fade to black then i
i
i mean i can't even believe they're
going out of the way to do this but
whoever replaces the velocity on
addict's vote yeah right so we're
looking at the change we're looking at
the change in the death rate if there's
any way to zoom in on that one chart
so you're looking at
the bottom of the chart is one to four
years old five to nine years old
over there you see people are living
longer 80 to 84
75 to 79. that means negative means that
they're living longer that their life
expectancy can be considered to be
longer and then you get 20 to 24 25 to
20 30 to 34. oh my god 35 to 39. 28
change in death rate yes
between 2019 2009 and 2019 21. it's
probably going to be worse if you run 20
20 20 21. well all these all these
people who've been isolated in their in
their house and every one of those
deaths is tragic because you're not
dying of some prolonged disease
you're at the prime of your life this is
when you're young
and and by look at the other data right
there percentage of 20 to 39 year olds
living
at home as reported 18 and 1980 was 50
just gonna continue to go up 1991 to 74
and then it was a drop-off in 2000 then
we went up to 20.3
then
23.7 percent 2020 and it's estimated to
be going up to 25 percent 24.99 2030.
because socialism is good for america
right teaching people how to go out be
independent work on their own make their
own households get out of their parents
basement and look what direction we're
going in that's too much so but i'm
still trying to understand tell me how
why this makes sense to create clinics
or places where people can go take
heroin what is the logic behind that
give me the laundry the only thing i can
think of
is if it's one of those if they're doing
it anyways let's supervise it to some
extent or let's try to and that's his
rationale let's try to gather it all in
one area like instead of it being
scattered around like hey let's just and
let's kind of like kind of hide it over
here i've taken up six trips to new york
and it is i mean
you can turn the corner and be like whoa
really that's what i was wondering is
how different does it feel oh i mean you
know i i have been gravitating towards
downtown downtown downtown like the
closer i get to the freedom tower the
more of a police presence i feel the
safer i feel
i mean i was always a midtown person but
midtown kind of freaks me out wow
boy that david we can hear you david
yeah you know the only thing i would say
is back in the late 80s new york was a
mess too and then once that's what it
feels like yeah one strong mayor can
change things but i don't know if
they're capable of bringing anyone in to
replace de blasio that could be better
and that's just given super chat
analysis from new york he said i'm a new
yorker and it's bad i want to give my
take they are even letting illegals vote
and they are forcing the vaccine on
students and city jobs i mean that's
just new york for you right now so what
does this do okay you know how they say
don't turn my texas into california
perspective new york city is eight
percent of u.s gdp
new york city
sorry i'm sorry sorry it's i'm sorry new
york state it's eight percent of you but
still
what is it
90 is the city i mean it's all about the
finance sector right yeah
insane to think about that but
interestingly enough though if they're
losing a lot of that how much is that
going to go down that's that's what i
mean i just said jp morgan chase has
more employees in texas texas than they
do in new york yeah but you you i'm
telling you in in texas you've seen this
before don't california my texas right
or in florida they say everywhere
everywhere don't bring your policies
down go to new york my florida you hear
that all the time it's a bumper sticker
so then the question becomes who are the
people that are leaving new york and
california okay or if they're just
bringing the same
mindset and ideology no but again
remember what i said that i'm starting
to hear from from transplanted
californians that they're uh they're
upset about
about critical race theory so i don't
think it's just liberals leaving i think
it might just be rational people
who don't want to pay
huge taxes and and support things like i
don't know heroin sites
it makes
zero sense to me so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]